[Music]
we're doing a series here we just did
one on food recently and we're moving
into utilities today to give you some
quick tips again none of these are
life-changing you're gonna roll your
eyes and say okay george shut the lights
off big whoop that's gonna save me big
money but i wanted to walk through some
of this because it really is interesting
so
inflation is the highest rate it's been
in 40 years but eight percent and since
february 2021 energy prices have gone up
by twenty five point six percent
so we've got a few quick tips here on
how to save when it comes to utilities
number one don't run appliances unless
they're full oh i don't know is that
great advice for money it irritates the
stew out of me when my when kids start
doing that there's three things
there's two things in the dishwasher
yeah let's pack it out man so uh and
what's interesting ken pre-rinsing waste
of time waste of water the dishwashers
today are made to get the gunk off all
right now i got to tell you something
tell that to stay stepping on my toes
i'm going to take that home with me i'm
not even kidding right now this was not
a
pre-rinse in fact i'm the guy that not
only do i pre-rinse i give it a little
bit of a scrub before i put it in there
why am i doing this now you own a
dishwasher ken you're telling me that i
can put it in there with the caked pasta
that was overcooked in the microwave i
have teenagers do you live on little
house in the prairie what's going on
here man use the dishwasher it's there
for you no you didn't answer my question
will it kelly knows i mean come on don't
look at teenagers it's not going to say
that you cook stuff in the microwave so
like the pasta and the cheese is like
embedded into the plate you're telling
me that the modern dishwasher will get
that off
listen i'm not here
well i'm not here to be the shamwow
pitch man to tell you how your
dishwasher is going to change your life
until i know folks i'm going to continue
with the rinse and light scrub before i
put it in the dish sounds like a
parenting problem it sounds like a
control issue i'm sure all right moving
on number two program your thermostat
i'm one of those millennials i've got
the smart thermostat this is big so if
you're not going to be home all day the
heat doesn't have to be pumping through
the house you can save as much as 10 a
year if you drop that thermostat down
and i know my wife is one of those who's
just constantly cold so we've got to
have the heat blast in but if you put on
a few layers you'll be okay what do you
have it on in the winter george i'm uh
i'm almost 70. oh that's in the winter
we are 66 degrees
at night in the winter 66 chilly i get
up in the morning and my feet hit the
tile in the bathroom it's like oh
welcome world i'm willing to wake up
fast i'm willing to pay that premium too
not me i sleep better when it's colder
by the way look it up
sleep sleep studies sure at night i drop
it down to 67. i said at night oh okay i
thought you meant during the day you
said 70. we're on the same page why are
we fighting ken we don't need to be
doing this in front of the kids in front
of america
all right so that's a big one though uh
and smart thermostats can help with this
at home
super easy can control it from my phone
by the way don't let the kids operate it
keep them away from it get a lock box on
when i was growing up my dad used to
threaten a beating uh you can't say that
anymore but like a real beating if i
ever touched the thermostat that was the
no go not allowed no touch that's smart
we need to get back to those days we do
all right lastly this is a no-brainer
use less so if energy costs are busting
your budget one of the best things you
can try to do is use less of it and that
means being intentional
even those little things it all adds up
turn off the lights turn off the water
while you brush your teeth all of that
stuff matters get led light bulbs
there's all these little things you
skipped over the light thing and that
should have been a major point george
thanks credit to you thank you first of
all led lights game changer you wouldn't
believe the energy savings they last
longer on top of that and here's the
other thing turn the daggum lights off
can't wait till all my teenagers are
married and in their own homes i'm going
to go to their house walk in every room
turn every light on we're just like the
old curmudgeon guys on like sesame
street in the balcony just telling the
kids to turn the lights off and get off
our lawns i'm just telling you i'm going
to take great pleasure they're getting
every light on leaving the refrigerator
door open to that end check your
insulation make sure there's no drafts
coming in make sure things are insulated
well
that's going to be big energy windows
change your filters that's a big one you
want to make sure all your appliances
are running efficiently so do a little
audit this weekend and see what happens
next month see if you don't save a few
bucks yeah a lot of people just tuned in
for the first time ever and they think
they're listening to a home improvement
show listen i'm tim the tool man taylor
yeah you wish so you can check out the
blog at ramseysolutions.com it's called
how to combat inflation and protect your
four walls we're going to be going
through some other areas like housing
and transportation coming up on the show
so stay tuned for that